panel conversation so don't be shy thank
you see these fine people are taking the
lead my name is Rebecca Peterson I'm the
senior research manager for harvardx at
Harvard University and it's my pleasure
to welcome you today to our inaugural
lightning round at the learning with
MOOCs conference our workshop this is a
experimental format as you see on your
program we have eight different research
presentations to deliver in the span of
60 minutes featuring full conversation
with all of you and to achieve that goal
each of our presenters will get three
minutes to give you an overview of the
research that they're doing and you'll
quickly find that the research being
presented today by our colleagues is
very diverse in the space so it's very
exciting our my colleagues here in the
front row our presenters are here up
front they're going to stick to a quick
three a really tight three-minute rule
so we can get through all of their
presentations so we can allow ample time
at the end for full group discussions so
I realize along the way many of you may
have questions please note them and hold
on to those so we can get through the
presentations after that everyone will
join us up here for a panel conversation
with the rest of you about the state of
research and given the morning
conversations and the sessions I expect
it to be lively and far-ranging so I'm
going to turn it over now to Carolyn
rozay from Carnegie Mellon University
who's going to start us off today Thank
You Carolyn hi there um so I will be
talking about our research on exploring
social factors that impact persistence
in MOOCs in addition to doing a variety
of analyses over many MOOCs to find
these social factors that are associated
with attrition we've also been
developing technology for interventions
to improve the social climate in MOOCs
and we have technology to share that's
the take home message this research that
we've been doing is based on a history
of doing research in online communities
more generally and I want to acknowledge
some of my colleagues from CMU and also
the University of Pittsburgh this is an
example analysis from an
my medical support community where we
see how important it is to receive
informational and emotional support in
maintaining commitment to a community
and you'll see a couple of these
survival curves in in my talk where we
see time of participation in the x-axis
probability of still being involved on
the y-axis this black line is average
attrition and those top two lines which
are more shallow show the impact of
having received a high amount of
informational and emotional support so
you can see how important that has been
and we see similar patterns across MOOCs
when we look at students who participate
in the discussions in particular we can
differentiate students based on how
interconnected they are in those
discussions and so here the blue lines
are sort of average attrition of those
students and you can see the yellow line
which is far more shallow is students
who have an above average number of
connections persistent connections and
when those connections start to drop out
that's where the the red line is so
students when they lose their support
also tend to drop out so we see here
evidence that students benefit from
having some support to keep them
involved in the course and we've been
developing technology to help students
find those support of others so some
students are less good at finding those
connections some students have questions
and they don't get answered and they get
frustrated and they leave confusion is a
factor that we have found that as
students are exposed to a lot of other
confused students or as they express
confusion themselves that's associated
with them dropping out but we think if
we can help them find the need that
they're needed support then we can have
an impact on their experience on their
learning and also their persistence so
my student de Young has been developing
some social recommendation algorithms to
try to do a global optimization over a
community to match up help seekers with
help providers we have also done over
many years studies of computer-supported
collaborative learning and we see how
valuable interaction is in that context
we have tools
that can support that effectively and
can be integrated easily into MOOCs and
I'm almost out of time but the idea
really is that if we can have these
affordances built in we can help to
address the problem that teachers have
limited resources for offering the
support that students need
it's probably not is it Mary it was okay
yeah hi we're Tim and locka from
adversity I've rizzoli European platform
oh sorry yeah so we're Tim and Lara from
diversity and diversity is European
platform there's not only futurelearn
out there so and yeah on our platform
whatever professors want to do an exam
that cannot be evaluated automatically
they basically can choose between three
different ways of evaluation and first
of all they can do it themselves would
be professor grading most of the time
they don't have the time to do this so
what do they do they go for a second
option they choose peer grading that
means I'm participants evaluating each
other but some do not really trust for
your grading so they say I need
something different and then we offer
pro grading and pro grading is that we
hire a small group of PhD candidates
that do the evaluation for them and Tim
and I we were really interested in
finding out and how good are pros and
peers in imitating professors grading so
we applied all of the three methods em
to one of our exams in one course and
we're happy to share all of our findings
with you but now we're just going to
give you one graph two results in one
question for further discussion so yeah
that's according to the recommendations
there was one hero graph it's basically
throwing yeah you can see it it's
basically showing the grades given to
our exam takers yeah the great range
from the from 0 to 4 and the graders
range from the PIAA graders and the
programmers and the professor graders
yeah that's the graph now the two
results and the first result is quite
obvious from the graph and probably not
surprising everyone it's that peers so
fellow students and just like good
grades so they like I'm giving three and
four and yeah and on the other hand the
professor and the pro graders they
already have a quite balanced a
distribution in their grading and this
result and what you can't see from this
graph is actually that the correlation
between the programming so the grading
of the hired PhDs and the professor is
at the professor grade is as weak as the
correlation between the peer grading and
the professor grading so to answer
Lara's question yeah the the hired PhDs
kind of failed in imitating the
professor grade in the same way as the S
the ps2 so yeah that it now the question
for the audience yeah it's kind of
learning theory question so is there
such a thing as a true grade or should
we you should we forget this idea and
probably most of you already have
answers in mind and we would be happy to
have a conversation on that so thanks
for your attention
great hello everyone my name is Chad
Evans Emma mm-hmm a graduate student at
the University of Pennsylvania this is
nicole wang a pen research fellow the
title of our presentations big data and
MOOCs this presentation is based on some
research that we've been conducting on
the Coursera course taking patterns and
we wanted to share with you four
problems and as well as some solutions
to these problems that we've experienced
while doing this analysis the first
problem that we experienced related to
the processing time with the big data
that we were working with computers are
generally great with calculations but
when you're working with hundreds of
thousands of rows of data it can cause
some serious problems and this affected
our data cleaning data management and
our debt analysis itself the second
problem we experience related to the
limited resources we felt that were
available for us many of our team was
neophyte research assistants some with
no experience in coding and we weren't
confident that there are good places to
acquire and share information in regards
to MOOC research the third problem
experienced related to the ambiguous
nature of the data that we were given
from Coursera we were essentially handed
a data dump and and then we were the
variable names and a lot of the data
inside of it were not exactly clearly
explained to us when we're we were
basically making some guesses as to what
things meant and when that happens we
couldn't always use all the data that
was there and then the final issue the
experience related to secure server
issues um you know personal information
now needs to be analyzed on these secure
environments and we had lots of problems
with cursor freezing and with the the
program dropping freezing as well as
some functionality lost in the computer
Nicole okay so you did have in panic we
call for the openness of codes and the
data analysis to contribute to future
data research so we're considering
building a move data a MOOC data
collaborative and community or
existing whoever is currently building
it and the share cost to the public to
assist other researchers and with like
the analysis under the secure server so
the idea of sharing the research Anna's
research analysis would be beneficial in
terms of the MOOC development and the
next one would be to create and it had
to create a data dictionary so the idea
of a standardized coding system that
covers most of the variables names would
be beneficial the third instead of like
that the big data so the future research
requires better data yes okay I'm
running on time so the first one with a
big so they are not IT staff so the
communication with the technology team
will be the key here's a word richest
team and bounding questions
only mouth sorry
okay so hi I'm Tiffany and i'll be
presenting iran joe and andrew hos
research on evaluating the flipped
classroom and an undergraduate chinese
history survey course so what is a
flipped classroom a flipped classroom
refers to a model that allows students
to learn course content traditionally
delivered in the classroom in our case
traditionally do Massari traditionally
delivered a classroom prior to the class
in our case on the EDX platform online
so that students can spend time engaging
in engaging active learning activities
in class and in our case and a
discussion format with cold calling
involved so the motivation behind this
study was to understand whether students
preferred the flipped classroom and if
they were more motivated based on the
flip classroom and more importantly if
it impacted their learning so it was a
quasi-experimental design comparing the
class taught in 2011 with the class it's
a traditional class with the class
taught in 2013 as a flipped classroom
keeping the midterm fixed and
controlling for differences in Raiders
tendency GPA and SATs scores and a
survey was awesome administered to the
2013 students to understand their
opinion about the flipped classroom
model so in the results across the range
of specifications the model suggests
that there were no statistically
significant difference in the midterm
exam scores however with the survey
results we found a larger president's
preferred the flipped classroom then
prefer the traditional classroom
compared and though compared to those
who had no preference and in the
open-ended responses we found that those
who prefer the flipped classroom I did
so because they like the short segments
to lecture content online they like that
there are more diverse opinions
presented in discussion than in a
lecture and that they could sort of
choose when to watch the lectures and
for those who prefer the traditional
classroom
they felt that there was too much time
required spent outside of classroom that
the cold calling was highly stressful
and that they preferred lecture in
general two on two discussion so our
recommendations are that this design
should be implemented more broadly to
attract the impact of classrooms and
also just to track longitudinally
improvement in learning in general and
this could be either using a pool of
assessments or low stakes assessments to
track learning improvements over time
and also because the flipped classroom
and blended learning is still in its
nascent stages more thought needs to be
put into the implementation of it and
that students expectations should be
made explicit to them since this is very
new for them as well thank you and for
more information please what read the
paper that they wrote and also Jenny
programs report on blended learning
thank you
who's next Sharif so you have to hi
everyone I'm sure if I'm a graduate
student in the learning analytics lab at
Stanford and we are one of the many
groups that are trying to study and
understand dropouts and try to mitigate
attrition in MOOCs through intervention
so we view this as a four-step process
so first you have to predict who is
going to drop out and then you have to
try to identify the relevant latent
factors that contribute to a learner's
dropout and then you have to also
identify the causes that you know that
develops at risk factors and then
finally you know with this sort of
knowledge you have to try to design and
deliver an intervention in a in a timely
manner so we've done some previous work
on step one which is predicting dropout
so you know you can refer to the lithics
lab at stanford.edu page for that we are
moving to the next step now so after we
have used the output predictor to red
flag students who are believed to be at
high risk of dropout the question now is
why so the study that I'm presenting
today consists of two parts the first
part is a survey that we sent in
actually it's just in one course so far
we are planning to repeat it in a number
of other courses so the survey basically
has two goals the first is to identify
relevant risk factors or latent factors
such as you know experience difficulty
or latter lack of volition for instance
try to identify the relevant latent
factors that contribute to your students
choice to drop out and also try to you
know the source from students what they
believe contributed to their drop out in
terms of actual physical reasons that
are measurable to us and so some of the
interesting findings that we got out is
that there are mainly five latent
factors that explained almost ninety
nine percent of the drop out so out of
these difficulty
of lack of motivation and lack of
volition which is a work habit a
negative work habit where a person does
not mobilize their motivation to
actually do work turned out to be you
know some of the most common reported
factors risk factors were basically used
rating because it's difficult for
students to understand the constructs
and distinguish between them whereas the
reasons why these risk factors were
developed these were actually left his
open-ended for students to report on
there you know what they believe
contributed to the development of the
risk factor so we also observed lack of
time as one of the significant
contributors and also lack of social
support as one of these significant
reasons for dropout difficulty was you
know manifest itself in many ways such
as difficulty understanding the content
or students would often report that
teachers would progress so fast from
concept to concept without offering
sufficient practice among forms of lack
of volition students reported for
instance that since this is not
something that they are you know
pressure to do then they would have
loved to be encouraged more to do it you
know just some these are just a few
findings and because I'm ready running
out of time the second part of the study
was to try to search for behaviors
predictive of the different you know
state of different latent factors what
we found is that you know by looking at
students engagement with assessments
videos it's possible to identify
features characteristic for highly
motivated students students with high
volition students experiencing
difficulty we found that by combining
these in you know in simple machine
learning models it's possible to
distinguish students who left leave
because of lack of volition for instance
from students who leave because of
difficulty from caesars to leave because
of lack of time
hi my name is Megan Morrissey and this
is you've already met my colleague
Tiffany Wong and I wanted to acknowledge
jun Ji Leo and we make up three fourths
of our China X course team at Harvard X
and our motivation for this study was to
better understand text length on
learning in an online context due to the
importance of reading in humanity
courses and the lack of research in this
area our course China X requires that
our learners be able to analyze and
concept contextualize primary and
secondary sources primarily textual in
order to study history as practitioners
as practitioners it's important for us
to base our creation of course content
on research China X is made up of 10
mini courses that span 15 months and
each mini course is four to eight weeks
forty four to eight weeks long and due
to the large quantity of do large
quantity of reading in specifically the
4th mini course transformers
transforming government transforming
society through government and our
subsequent mini-courses we really wanted
to optimize text length and to better
understand what would work the best for
our learners and also in line with
Harvard X's three goals of reach
research and recirculation to
residential we are constantly trying to
improve and iterate on in the most
immediate our online classroom and
residential blended classroom
as well as to the broader learning
community and now Tiffany is going to
talk you through the experimental design
of our study so we had an a/b
experimental design where learners were
randomly assigned to group a or group a
bait when they clicked on the reading
for group a they would get all the texts
in one segment and for group B they
would get the text and shorter chunks so
on the platform it looks like this
learners have to scroll for group a and
for groupie it's they have to click
through the segments and so we found
that there was no significant difference
in terms of correlation between text
length and assessments met measured like
through a certification rate answer its
and their correct answer and we measured
return we wanted to measure learning
through measured by assessments and
retention measured by completion of text
and completion of course as a whole and
we found that in terms of the learning
there was no sort of significance and
this is also the same reflected in other
studies done on textual physical
readings and in terms of the in terms of
retention tension learners spent more
time on and Group B but that may be just
because of click time and a fraction a
larger proportion of learners finished
the readings in Group A but that also
may be because we could only measure
click time so in conclusion we believe
that more research needs to be done on
this topic and we are very open to
collaboration thank you
hi my name is Renee cottage from the
lytic slab at Stanford this is Emily
Schneider also from the same lab we'll
be giving a quick overview of the things
that we've been doing in the past two
two-and-a-half years instead of going
into much depth for any one of them so
I've been working on understanding
learners more especially by looking at
their behaviors and courses as well as
looking what motivations what
motivations drives them to the courses
and also what their subsequent actions
are then like so it's a more
observational analysis we're doing this
with Emily and some other collaborators
another line of work has been on
promoting learner success using
psychological interventions specifically
using goal interventions that helps
learners foster commitment and striving
to what their goals and also feelings of
social belonging feeling like they're
that the online learning environment is
a place dead that they belong in a third
line of work is social factors in MOOCs
many many MOOC platforms have rather few
social opportunities for learners to
engage in and so some things I've been
looking at there is the instructors face
in video lectures and what effect that
face has on learner retention cognitive
load feelings of social presence and
also embedding social cues in the
platform such as telling learners how
many other learners are currently
watching this video with them right now
what effect that has on the waste day
they see these the opportunity perfect
timing thanks yeah and so some of the
other work that I've been doing with
other clever collaborators in the lytic
slab is looking into some of the
qualitative aspects of learning
experiences so we've been seeing a lot
of data-driven investigations of how
people engage with courses and so we
started doing some interviews with with
learners to see what their experience is
like when writing that up in a paper
right now but one of the big things is
sort of the invisible practices that
aren't captured by the log
data that really give context and
meaning to people's participation in
MOOCs and social aspects there again is
a really big piece both their social
their interactions on platforms other
than the MOOC platforms and also they're
sort of in-person interactions with
family and friends and others who are
supporting their their participation in
the course which is also interestingly
something we saw in our large-scale
large data investigation based on survey
data and correlations of student
activities that students who who
enrolled with other friends or
colleagues in the course stayed really
involved with the course and then sort
of another thing that I'm really
interested in is sort of tools to help
learners construct their own knowledge
in the courses and this is so started
working on annotation and note-taking
tools if you're interested in that kind
of also to fill in Leo's talk after this
but basically what can we built into the
platform to help people make knowledge
their own and also have conversations
that are really directly attached to the
text into the other resources so three
seconds two seconds one second thanks a
lot now the last Speaker John gets the
rest of the hour is that right yeah
actually right yeah so mine's actually
not on active research because what I'm
talking about is actually building an
infrastructure to support researcher
research I'm one of my roles is as the
data's are for uqx and so it was very
important to me that for the University
of Queensland I deliver their maximum
bang for buck or value out of the data
that gets collected so I wanted a nice
infrastructure that provided the
services from that data for the
different audiences such as our
management course teams and researchers
so we're building a system based upon
the national research infrastructure
which is
oh sorry we're building an
infrastructure based on the national
research infrastructure in Australia
which was intended to provide services
for researchers to share data so we're
using that we're building this in
similar sort of way to the way the EDX
platform works so you'll be able to fork
our get repository and run the ansible
script and provision yourself a
dashboard server that will be able to
ingest data from the data sources so
here here all our data sources we are
the primary ones from EDX of the data
dumps but we also have a number of LTI
tools that we run it in our courses
which are hosted on our servers we also
have apache logs from the video
downloads we've the download link for
all the videos if someone doesn't want
to watch on YouTube and downloads comes
from our service or we can track all of
those and we actually have an asset
database which is created during the
course design process so we potentially
in the future when our learning
designers get their act together we'll
actually have information in there about
the assets in the course about why
they're there what they're learning
goals were and so forth we ingest all of
this into the data layer which is 10
terabytes of storage at the moment and
then we have a processing server which
has got a plug-in architecture that
allows you to plug in in jesters that
ingest the data into query databases SQL
or and processes that do
processing of the data things like
changing IP addresses to countries
generating person coarse aggregate data
sets and so forth and it saves those
data sets back onto the storage and then
we have our dashboard which is a set of
plugins that do all of the
visualizations and provide the interface
so you go to that the web page you
select the course you select what
visualization you want and it either
queries the databases or uses one of the
derived data sets to present that and
then the next step so all of that's
pretty much built and hopefully will be
released in the next couple of weeks and
the next step is to build the ad hoc
query tools that allow researchers that
don't know what they're after to go in
and do ad hoc queries on the databases
and access these derived data sets
directly and 0 seconds thank you thank
you everyone I just want to take a quick
just to make a comment to take to have
researchers who spent two years months
to get to these results and tell them
you have three minutes to present your
findings um you did a wonderful work so
random opposed to them again as I thank
you an also to Russ traitor who has been
our tech AV over here Thank You Russ I
want to invite the panelists up here to
the chairs hopefully we have enough for
all of you will scrounge up a few extras
and we wanted to allow a plentiful
enough time for us to have an open
dialogue and I think actually John's
presentation right there at the end in
some ways was a nice way for those of
you that might be new to MOOC research
or have enjoyed over the last year to
seeing the research that's a movie
emerging out of the MOOC space John's
presentation that I think is a nice
illustration in some ways of the
underbelly of what it takes to do the
work that a lot of the folks up here and
a lot of you in the room have been
undertaking and I think it's fair to say
that we're still in very early days I
have one question for the panel to kick
it off and then I'm going to turn it
over to you just from some ground rules
like this morning there are people
floating around with microphones so
don't be shy the only thing I would ask
you to do when you go to ask your
question introduce who you are so we
know where you're from and then also
direct your question
you want to if it's for the full panel
or certain panelist but real quickly i'm
curious for anyone who wants to take a
stab at this there's a microphone that
you'll get to pass down what was when
you were going through to do your
research and i picked this off of the
twitter stream actually well you were
all presenting what were I don't wanna
get into a long policy conversation but
what words of wisdom might you have
about the IRB process maybe for a lot of
your colleagues we talked about data
collection and John gave us a snapshot
of that but those of us who are
undertaking research in this space
there's a lot of considerations if any
of you want to give and I want you to
give more advice fanta so you'd walk
through this the holdat gory details of
IRB in this brave new world but just
advice or wisdom you might give folks
who are interested in pursuing research
in this space as they get this approved
to their institutions anyone wanted
people to go ahead Renee from Stanford
thanks Megan yes the IRB one one one
piece of advice that I would really have
for people looking into this and working
with the IRB is that the IRB is there to
help you and it's most important to have
an open conversation about what you're
trying to get out of it and what the IRB
has to offer you on doing the right
things and and be we really open and
work together with the IRB instead of
instead of seeing it as an obstacle in
the way of you doing your research I
think that that's the one piece of
advice that I would have so I think the
really most important thing is that the
instructors of the course have gone
through the process up front and making
sure that the data can be shared for
research purposes and also um it's very
complicated because the providers have
their data agreement sometimes
universities kind of sign things without
realizing what they're signing over and
they may not be fully aware there's
usually a data coordinator at the
university who may not know then you
have to get all these people on the same
page it ends up being a really really
long process the one very successful
case i can think of was really led by
norman beer who i believe is either here
or
he's a close collaborator with people
who are here he did it right and he
would be a great person to talk to
thanks Carolyn I'm Megan do you have
I'll just keep running back and forth
and I would just add to that our team
has done to I arbys and I would say that
the design of whatever you're testing
that the instructional designer is
working extremely close with the
researcher so that you have every detail
from the very beginning worked out with
the instructor and in this case Tiffany
was fundamental in the design of it
because she knew the content very well
as Renee said just like keeping in mind
that it's and you're you're just trying
to make sure that your students have the
best learning experience that they can
have and so it's a lot of it is common
sense and it's like if if you think that
you would want to be in that situation
that it's probably you know like if if
you're trying to make it so that the
learners can learn the best that they
can and so working closely with your IRB
person to make sure that that's possible
is beneficial and I'm just going to add
one point and one of the reasons why i
asked that is just because i think MOOCs
have presented an interesting
opportunity we got into this covers he
shoulda just yesterday at harvard we had
some folks over from stanford and other
universities and this is a great rich
space that's very interdisciplinary and
so there are social scientists and
others that are very used to going
through the IRB process and there are
other researchers that are getting more
into this field and the data sciences
and computer science that the
institutional review board process is
probably a little bit new as well so
it's more just something to be aware of
joseph did you have something to add to
this or reduce yourself and i am joseph
williams i'm it's done for now and
moving to Harvard X in September but
just a follow-on um there's a she can
have an opportunity for a platform to
shield you from being in possession of
information that puts you at risk on
flex lunas at res so i'm neil Heffernan
who's that was Polytechnic he runs a six
months which is a platform that
it is kind of like a MOOC it's for high
school community college and it's
actually something you can use to run
experiments and moves as well but here
she got an NSF grant i Doan the advisory
board for it on a key part of it is that
researchers can apply to run experiments
which he then embeds but you actually
never get any personally identifiable
information and so you are shrikant
really disclose learners information so
that actually makes a lot safer for
learners aren't for you so I'm not sure
if that's something that MOOC platforms
or universities could look into but
that's great because it actually by
blocking information from you it
protects you and protects learners
another thing is that assessments then
make sure that when you're running
research it has to be Dave do a
clearance that it's going to be
instructionally effective it's not
research just we seek research because
it's practical that actually also
changes the kind of IRB that you're
requesting expressive other questions
follow us in I guess this is like the
one there's a mic right there I am I
damage Eric I'm from the center for 21st
century universities and georgia
institute of technology I'm the
dedicated data controller for Coursera
data and also the IRB designated person
to write all of the IRB s for all of our
moves and there may I learned like a
comment about a consent form and an
issue that we're facing when we are
writing consent forms we really use
language that is pretty practical that
allows the instructor who is also a
researcher and I'm identified as a
researcher on these protocols as well
access to the data over a period of time
but we're working on something right now
and I'll bring to your attention is that
the language that you use has to be a
little bit more strategic what about if
someone from marketing wants to come and
utilize your data to market that
particular course if that person is not
on the consent form it's going to be
very difficult for marketing to get
access to the data so I just wanted to
bring that to your attention it's
practical language that we're using and
yes you work with the art be they are
very friendly and they're very helpful
but think about being a little bit more
strategic who else would want to see
that data as
point I'm thank you questions go ahead
Adam over yes I think in thinking about
these courses one of the things we're
all interested in engagement is
engagement the student engagement but is
focusing on students who drop out versus
those who don't drop out really an
effective way of getting at engagement
given especially in the case of fully
open courses where students invest
nothing into the course up front
students might have lots of different
motivations for taking it and I wonder
if we're missing the really interesting
aspects of the data if we're just
focusing on dropouts where does not drop
out I'll just give us your answer and
then I am sure others have something to
say about this so I've heard this
question come up over and over again
what we see is that there are several
different kinds of students there are
those who are shopping around and if
they drop out it's probably not a big
deal but we have a lot of evidence that
there are students who fully intend to
keep going in a course they struggle and
they're just not able to overcome their
struggles and they drop out and we see
this in post course surveys we see this
in what they talk about in the
discussion forums and we hear it from
people offline as well and so I think
it's important to distinguish between
those two look for signs of struggle and
try to support those struggling students
and we can measure our success in terms
of reductions in dropout rates because
it's one way of seeing you know did we
help people overcome their struggles but
but I I think we shouldn't be too
distracted by the fact that there is a
lot of window shopping yeah and I'll
just say quickly to Sharif because he's
been addressing this um I think one one
of the reasons this has been a big part
of the conversation is because we've
been trying to understand who do we
quote unquote really care about who do
we want to work to support and who is it
okay to sort of let go and it's it's
problematic language I agree but it sort
of where's the especially when the free
courses where's the responsibility of
the instructor and of the platform to
sort of help the entire population or
can we can we divide up the population
in a meaningful way to target feedback
or target interventions that will help
that specific group of students so just
sort of understanding that
sketching out the landscape has been a
really important first stage in this
research and I think or moving beyond it
so I guess one one other thing is when a
policymaker and an instructional
designer talk about drop out probably
inside each of their heads they mean
different things so since there are many
different definitions for dropout than
one you know consequence of this is that
basically different people are focusing
on different type of behaviors or
outcomes undesirable outcomes so you can
imagine for instance is an instructional
designer might be interested in students
who declare intention of viewing all of
the videos and then seem to progress at
a really low pace or just leave the
course before completing half of the
videos that might be an interesting case
but for someone interested in not
basically taking the final exam for
instance but developing an ability to
you know to have an effective and you
know an efficient conversation in the
field with other people so people
looking for basically social engagement
in the course the deficient the
definition of dropout and consequently
the research and everything Underwood's
might be really different question way
up in the car like in the bright lights
I just wanted to quick add one point um
the dropping out is one measurement it's
one thing that we can look at in these
data sets but it's really only one
dimension there's so many different
outcomes that you could look at so I
think that I think that an important
part of the research process is to work
with whoever's collecting the data in
order to design questions that can get
at different outcomes that we care about
because people take course there are
classes or any mu class for a whole
range of motivations and it's important
to recognize the value and the different
outcomes that they're pursuing hi I'm
Maria Gianelli from the American Museum
of Natural History in New York City and
my question is for the folks from Penn I
am also wrestling with course eras data
exports and I'm not doing it
successfully and so I'm wondering how
you ultimately did that did you
the hire somebody who had familiarity
with the data did you work with the
folks from Coursera how'd you do it and
are you sharing your sequel scripts um I
don't know how on other universities
handle it but Penn has someone
specifically designated as our lies on
with Coursera um so it's with this
individual that we communicate we put in
requests and so forth in regards to the
code we have a tech team in the
Department of the education school at
Penn that does all of our my sequel
stuff and if you want to talk with us
after this conference I'd be happy to
share with you that contact and and I
would encourage you to pursue that and
and also I think various our relation
manager in Kucera and you can talk to
because they assign in different
universities with the one you want to
talk to in terms of like the questions
you have or like if you have like any
type of concerns etc so that person
would be very beneficial to your
research as well yes Stanford has
andreas Papke at Stanford is the data
manager he's been doing a great job and
making the data more and more accessible
and we actually have an online forum now
at Stanford where anyone from around the
world can submit his or her idea for for
conducting research what kind of data
they would need for that research and
then these requests are evaluated
internally and reviewed and that is our
process of sharing data with other
researchers outside of Stanford I'm just
as a quick add on we also have a bunch
of scripts and models that we would be
willing to share from some of our
published research on analyses of
Coursera daiva and so if people are
interested we would pass on our papers
you could take a look at what we did if
you're interested we're happy to partner
with you
yeah its diversity you also have lots of
data and lots of research ideas so yeah
at the moment I'm doing this so if you
have ideas or questions you can just
write me an email I think the email rest
popped up a lot of times they're so
yes when Stephanie first so we have
freely available systems online Oh
should I do okay hi I'm chin my from
Stanford we work with Coursera in the
past on peer assessment and we have
freely available scripts online on
github which will run these scripts on
your own data and make suggestions for
things like oh yeah this question was
very confusing to everybody in your
class maybe you should reword it so we
can create these data driven suggestions
and the code is available online and if
you go to research dot P o studio or you
can find it or you can just find me and
our point you to it again right Thanks
can I actually add something to that
right at Stanford we are also working on
developing the movie be parking strips
for Coursera and that implies you know
some data science techniques to
basically filter the data and clean it
up and mukti be basically provides you
know Coursera data in a format that is
really you know very easy to deal with
so if you're also interested you know
reach out to me we're preparing pilots
for people interested in working with
course are dead under MOOC TB thank you
a very different question Cormac McGrath
from karolinska institutet so this is a
question for the iversity people we're
going to be publishing a course come
spring in randomized control trials and
we were hoping to build it around a pair
assessment so you kind of broke my
bubble with your presentation at the
same time your results sort of
contradict a lot of the research out
there which shows a very high
inter-rater reliability between students
and teachers and teachers and teachers
etc etc so I'm curious do you think your
findings have got something to do with
it being MOOC specific or or you want to
something there yeah I'm not sure if
it's really MOOC specific I mean it's
not yeah I mean we had this viet appears
that some also exists offline we had em
progresso like teaching assistants and
enter professor so
yeah and what was the the first question
actually before there was only one
question I think so they're seeing
there's a lot of research to suggest
that there was a very high interrater
reliability but your suggest or your
results suggest that in this case anyway
there wasn't almost any exactly so I
think the this high correlation exists a
few if you apply more more fancy
algorithms and methods to the to the
grading so there are machine learning
methods or I think there's a paper from
Coursera well where a lot of statistics
is applied but we were really applying
it to a basic model of peer grading
we're just five people and great me I
grade five people and then the end we
take something like the average but
without taking to account all this other
spices and trying to trying to fix this
problem because we were thinking that
before trying to fix this with fancy
algorithms we should think what we want
to have to optimize for is it is there
really such a thing as a true grade and
who is determining it is the professor
or are there three grades like one from
the professor one from PS one from
teaching assistants so we wanted to do
this first and then apply more advanced
methods I guess I'll give up a mic and I
was just a closing comments and i don't
think that surely the answer isn't in
the algorithms to peer assessment so my
question was and i'll let the question
go now but i'm just curious when you
inflate or you scale up a MOOC to so
many people then maybe people aren't
invested in giving good feedback and
that's the question I'd like or that's
the issue I'd like to talk more about
but not here because I think my times up
so thanks Laura do you write something
directly related Laura Laura whiner from
mcgill university I'm just wondering
what kind of rubrics were being used by
the TAS by the profs by the piers that's
my question yeah so um like the profs or
the prof am the piers and the pros used
the same rubrics and there were five
criteria there was one on sourcing like
citation how well did they do that
yeah and there was one related to
content of course then another one was
whether the argumentation was balanced
and the fourth one was about the the the
general like history thesis but we also
found that one issue is that they were
performed very good in the content part
but whenever it came to methods applying
like the method of writing a scientific
sa they perform very poorly and this is
basically because I mean they're so the
audience is so diverse and they have
different backgrounds and we assume that
a lot of them have never taken a course
on scientific writing so they were
completely overwhelmed with this task so
this is something that we found very
interesting and that we would like to
look at even closer because you know one
it's like teaching content the other
thing is teaching methods and we found
that that was a gap in this course we
have time for one more question and I
believe there's been some more of a
suggestion that a question may be but
Rebecca it would be great if you could
maybe sorry Margot chanel from
Stony Brook back to the data and
exporting from coarser we also had a bit
of a nightmare with that but then
everything worked out but it would be
great if somewhere on the website for
this conference if maybe you could
collect the sights and the algorithms
and the things that at least the panel
discussed I think that would be super
useful for everyone we'll figure that
out i'm looking at canvas and ross
definitely that's a great suggestion and
i actually wanted to comment I know
Candace you mentioned this morning there
is I think up at the registration desk
also a sign in sheet for the broader
research community so we're trying to
get together a mailing list as well so
all of you that are here you know we're
going old school but very reliable
technology actually people still like
their email I know I do I'm not
completely on Twitter all the time but
this is a good the idea through this is
to build community continue the
conversation from this and to share also
not only put it on the website but as
things come up to share these valuable
resources like Coursera addicts also has
resources on get as well all of the
providers
I know Olga if you want to know more
about that i'm going to point out olga
sitting right there he's waving she can
talk to you a little bit more about what
are the analytics team at EDX has been
working on as well but overall I just
want to take the time to I just
realizing that we're coming to a close
any final thoughts from the panelists
other than I want to commend you all for
being able to do your research talk in
three minutes and also all of you for
being here and having a great
conversation there feel free to come up
I think people linger a little bit if
you have any individual questions for
the panelists feel free to come up we
have a break for the next half hour
before the next session so thank you
everyone Thank You panelists